in America for less than $200 you can go
get any business registered at the City
Hall and call yourself a CEO you can
even get a business card and call
yourself a CEO and give you a business
card when saying man I'm a CEO but you
know when you're a real CEO when
hundreds of other people call you a CEO
because you've earned the right for
other people to see you as a CEO so
today today before you become a CEO one
must act behave walk talk think like a
CEO before you become a CEO way before I
became a CEO I worked on thinking like a
CEO walking like a CEO asking myself how
would make a decision like a seal and
then I became a CEO and then once I was
called the CEO years later other people
started seeing me as this year then the
rest was history so today qualities of a
great CEO and I'm telling this from a
lot of my personal mistakes on what can
help you out for one day being a CEO and
maybe one day you aspire to become a
great seal but regardless if you ever
plan on becoming a great CEO or not
you're going to learn a lot of things
you can do to help yourself with your
leadership ability so I've got 19
different points to give you and I'll
get right into it point number one point
number one great CEOs know how to manage
their ego let me explain
nobody becomes a CEO who doesn't have an
ego nobody
not a single soul becomes a CEO who
doesn't have an ego nobody becomes the
president United States when I've been a
little bit mentally off to believe you
have the best processor to make
decisions you got somewhat of an ego
right so you got to realize people who
don't have egos don't want to be
President so there's nothing wrong with
having a big ego but you've got to learn
how to manage your own ego because if
you don't control your ego you're
definitely in trouble let me explain why
when you become very successful and you
start making a lot of money and
everybody knows you and you have Fame
and all this other stuff there's
something that happens and let me tell
what that one thing is it's called you
are flooded with compliments okay you
are flooded with compliments let me give
you the compliment oh you're so amazing
or you're so ridiculously good or you're
better than this or you're better than
and so many people are going to feed you
this stuff because you're surrounded
around people that are afraid of the
decisions you can make to fire them so
everybody wants to tell you how amazing
you are right let me tell you 90% of it
is life okay just just want you to know
that because most people are not going
to tell you what you need to hear if you
have a small circle of people around you
that are telling you the truth you need
that because that's going to help you
manage your ego if you don't ever if you
no longer talk to the guys that tell you
off and are not afraid or tell you
things you need to hear and I'm talking
about small board that you have or
mentors that you have that are willing
to fix you and tell you otherwise you're
going to be in trouble I've seen this
happening so many times I've been
dealing with salespeople for a long time
they start making money everybody starts
telling them how amazing they are
they're no longer coachable now wanted
to learn they don't listen to anything
they'll say they know every single thing
because they already knows they forgot
how to manage your own ego
now that's step number one let me tell
you step number two a great deal they
have a way of finally realizing that
they need to get a touch of humility in
them here's why you know my humility
helps because other people want to work
with you if you don't have humility you
can't bring people together if you don't
have humility people would disagree with
you don't want to do business with you
if you don't have humility you can't
have an environment with a lot of
different personalities because they
have to be in a certain set of
personality to be able to work with you
humility is extremely needed point
number three CEOs are extremely driven
what I did last week can you give me
that pack it right there on the bag
right there yes just me the whole bad no
no give me the whole back yeah so I
brought all the edge we can say hi to
everybody but it doesn't this is head
girl okay Edgar newa new teammate of
ours for about a month and a half so
last two weeks ago I invited some of the
biggest insurance companies in the world
CEOs all these different people showed
up we took them to a nice dinner at
Capital Grille in Dallas at Crescent
which is my favorite building in the
world is the Crescent fastly I just
wrote a last five years I wrote this
book it's a fiction books my first
fiction book I've ever written the
entire book was inspired by this
building the Crescent the setting is
that a building that looks like the
Crescent
so we had dinner at Capital Grille and I
brought them to dinner and normally in
the insurance industry they pay for our
dinner I pay for everybody it's not a
cheap dinner a few thousand dollars then
the following day the Crescent has a
seventeenth floor to country it's a club
where President Bush goes and other
president many different presidents both
on the left on the right have been to
this club and there's a lot of strong
billionaires oil people that go over
here I rented an entire room and I took
them over there we had lunch from 8
o'clock in the morning till noon
I presented tenor with the 2017 vision
when we have this meeting and it's a
room filled with a lot of egos for a lot
of egos and everybody is products we
sell their products ok and they're all
multi-billion dollar companies these are
all multi-billion from ranging from a
ten billion dollar company to a 300
billion dollar company they're all in
the room and we're presenting all this
stuff that I'm sharing with all these
guys this is how the meeting us started
the first thing I said I got a gift for
you typically these meetings start in a
different would like I got a surprise
for you I said first we need to realize
that ego is the enemy and we all need to
set aside our egos if we don't lead with
humility and we lead purely with ego
nothing's going to get done if you're
willing to set aside your egos we're
willing to set aside our egos hopefully
we can do something big together this
doesn't mean I'm negotiating I'm not
going to stop negotiating because I'm
going to ask for a bigger contract but
this needs to be set aside simple as
that give it to everybody we laughed we
had fun they enjoyed it then I give them
the next hat here and this hat doesn't
say make America great again obviously
we're trying to have some humor with
these guys it said can you zoom in can
you zoom in and see exactly what it says
it says make insurance cool again right
make insurance cool again the reason why
I gave them these hat is because there's
nothing cool about life insurance if
you've ever been to a life insurance
traditional convention with all these
insurance companies go to it it's pretty
bad when you go to it so we came from
this hat everybody starts laughing
making surance we took a picture
everybody took the picture again
together and I said we got make
insurance cool again what's the
likelihood of doing that it's very
difficult for a lot allottee but we're
doing it we made a cool Millennials love
if our firm we have multi-culture the
average agents in our companies a 34
year old Hispanic female while America
right now struggling to get Hispanics
multicultural and Millennials and Gen
Xers to become Asian and we're very good
at that so I give them this hat and
everyone starts laughing the next thing
we gave them was a phone charger the
phone charger said every single time you
charge your phone I want you to think
about that we're going to power up the
entire industries what we're going to be
doing so next time you charge in your
phone think about us because we're
probably out there growing the industry
and last but not least what I gave them
was the following here's what I give
them
we gave them two cigars Romeo and
Julieta okay two cigars and the reason
why we got these two cigars for them I
said the following term I said look in
business sometimes we end up spending
more time with people we're in business
with then our own family because that's
just kind of how business works you
travel and you doing all this other
stuff I said it's even greater if you
can enjoy doing business with people
that you enjoy being in business with
and I said I hope we can take our
business relationship on what it is
today to Friendship by sharing many
different cigars together so you and I
can get to know each other so we make
tens of millions of dollars together but
at the same time we establish a
relationship with you as well are you
open to that yes then we kicked off the
meeting that's how the meeting got
started now why am I telling you this
here's why I'm telling you this we're
extremely driven everybody in the room
is driven everybody's got ego but we
have to figure out a way to set aside
the ego and manage this and lead with
this for everybody else to open up and
say fair enough let's do business
together this is one of the things that
a CEO has to CEO typically starts off
with a lot of this because this is what
survives and you just want to kill
everybody and compete on all the stuff
and then you realize sometimes you're
killing your own allies did your friends
you're killing you know how there was
some time you play those video games and
you kill the wrong person and you lose
you killing your own allies that's not
smart because your ego we need to lead
with this and you need to know how to
manage your ego while still being driven
while still known you're going to be
dealing with a lot of other driven
people number four care for their people
great seals care for their people if you
ask any of the ceos like i got a call
the other day from a guy
I worked with a long time ago his name
is Stefan let me tell you what he called
me and told me he called me in he and I
were speaking something on the private
side I'm gonna talk to this guy for
longest time and I was mentoring him way
way way many years ago he was like
family right I protected this guy looked
over him I wanted to make sure he had a
very good life enjoyed himself I enjoy
the company of his mom dad sister
everybody with his family now certain
things happen he called me says Pat
every single time I make a decision I
say to follow it I say what would
Patrick do in this situation right and
he said some of the best times they had
in business was working with you I
haven't learned as much as I learned
except when I was working with you let
me tell you why it's so important to
care for people I got another cup from a
guy named Danny
I won't tell us last name Danny he
called me he was in tears he called me a
year and a half ago and it wasn't phew
cease if you have no idea how reluctant
I've been about calling you because it's
been a decade I said Danny what's going
I remember everything about the people
that work I know their stores because I
care for the people on though their
stores and he says to me says Pat I
gotta tell you something man he's quiet
I'm like like this guy crying I haven't
talked to you for 10 years he says I'm
now the president of the bank I work at
I'm doing very well
I am married I am so happy I can't even
tell you I'm making a multi six-figure
income and I'm here to tell you
everything I'm putting in this
leadership position is the stuff I
learned when I was working in you in the
business with you you may be watching
this you're in Malaysia you in Brazil
you and I will never meet each other
possibilities of us meeting each other
maybe never right but you may realize
that the only way you will ever be
called a great CEO is if you realize the
most important product you will ever
have as a CEO is the people around you
if you forget that you're in deep
doo-doo let me tell you they make you
look good
without them you're not existent so if
you think the world revolves around you
as a CEO you're in deep trouble without
them nothing happens and by the way
there's fake care and people can tell
and there's real sincerity and
authenticity about you truly caring
about the people around you by the way
most people know how to read through the
BS you truly got to care about your
people
to ask yourself how often you care about
your people do you think about their
dreams their goals what they want their
purpose to become a reality are you
thinking from that standpoint if you are
you're going to becoming a pretty solid
CEO one day number five human nature you
got to study human nature why human is
great CEOs understand human nature
because they realize a very very long
time ago their number one product is not
technology I was at a Dallas Cowboys
game they lost to the Packers tough game
man let me tell you we're at the game we
had box seats we're with this technology
guys we're doing a bit of a negotiation
with them and a CEO of this company they
did about 100 million dollars last year
so Tom asks him a question about hey how
long have you been coding he says I've
never coded in my life so wait a minute
you saw that we kind of maximum checks
to you you never could have never caught
in my life have you never cause I'm
never quoted in my life
him and the biz dev guy have never
quoted in their lives but they were both
good in one thing human nature human
nature because the number one product is
not coding the number one product is not
insurance annuities all this other stuff
by the way if you are a CEO and you know
your products very well you've got an
edge on everybody so don't take this for
a moment for you to say well thank God
because I know nothing about my product
on that so I'm not giving you an out so
don't take you out there hang out come
back here you got to learn the product
but the number one product above all is
human nature you got to know what
happens when people are down why this
person's not all in why this person's
being a little bit forgetful what's the
personal life gone you got to take them
out to lunch and toppings and is
everything okay how's your wife doing
has you know such-and-such doing or the
kids get housing you got it this is all
the stuff you gotta know about because
it's relationships business is purely
relationships right number six
comfortable handling contradictions this
is very difficult for a lot of people
let me explain so anytime I try to
develop somebody into becoming a CEO or
an entrepreneur somebody that's running
their own business they are so like my
business only black and it's just white
I'm a black and white type of person and
this the only lack of this was black and
white like listen I I wish life was
black and white my life is not black in
my life is blue sometimes it's white
sometimes it's black sometimes sometimes
pink green purple sometimes is colorful
sometimes it's great it's there
weird so if you go into business
expecting just black and white you're
going to miss out on 80% of the
opportunities there are some great areas
in business and it's about learning how
to deal with contradictions what am I
talking about with contradictions on one
side one can say hard work you know you
gotta work hard to go out and be
successful 100% rule but your kids
working smart is what you got to become
successful and these guys may be true
sometimes some know it's all about hard
working hard you know it's all about
working smart now of course you need to
work smart and have tools but if I got a
guy that knows how to work hard and
manages energy and it's health and he
knows how to work smart by having the
right tools and people around them he's
going to kick the other guys but that
only thinks about working hard or
anything about working smart she gotta
warn that there's a lot of
contradictions in life and in business
you know build successes happiness is
about living a balanced life okay okay I
mean what is so balanced about being
pregnant having a kid and 24/7 a woman
all they have to think about it
pregnancy nursing we have several I've
okay with or you know people that want
to bring their kids here to work they're
pumping milk all day long so what do you
what is the balance life about it well
you're nursing the kids seven eight
times a day and they're pooping and this
your life is not balanced but let me
explain to you one of the biggest hides
is having a kid but life is about being
balanced right you got a person that's
chasing to win a championship a Super
Bowl place and movie six months they're
shooting not a balanced life so what is
balance is this like certain balance is
supposed to be 9:00 to 5:00 so you got
to know how to deal with contradictions
as a CEO and you got to dance with
contradictions man and don't be stiff
when you're dancing with contradiction
just kind of dance with contradictions
and be okay with it when you're dealing
with these contradictions because if you
don't you're going to have a lot of
anxiety attacks and you're going to be
having a lot of migraines if you try to
control all these contradictions number
seven they think outside the box
solid CEOs they think outside the box
it's not always one way of doing
anything they think outside the box they
regularly think outside the box one of
the videos I did on thinking outside the
box is you know how to think big as an
entrepreneur that's the video you ought
to watch it has to do a little bit with
how to think outside the box
but they don't just look at one thing I
think we have to do this business did
the verge get out looking at this thing
and you know connected that I think it's
this from why I never thought about the
yeah this year we need to focus on this
we've never done this before and they're
willing to think a little bit
differently than most people would think
number eight they have a reputation let
me explain what I mean by a reputation
they can't be pushed around by
competitors typically strong steals I
was watching this one president of a
company and he went up there and he was
being pushed around by Elizabeth Warren
and it's this is a financial firm
company I was watching and she was just
pushing and pushing and I'm sitting them
saying where is your spine stand up all
right it was a loss mark I'm not stand
up already stand up for your industry
you're making it you're making everybody
look like you're doing something wrong
have some backbone
say something you just sitting there
like this shaking because he's worried
about a six million dollar bonus like
say something already he's no longer the
president I wouldn't have them as the
president voice your opinion a little
bit you can't be a CEO representing the
industry and you don't have a backbone
to share your thoughts and opinions
because you're worried about regulators
and the government got to say some stuff
a little bit
I'm not time I've being disrespectful
but you can just sit there and take it
all the time a seal can be pushed around
you can't bully a CEO they stand up one
of the most respectable seals I've ever
met was his name was Bob memo shape we
established a relationship together at
our conference in 2015 I will never
forget he died that night during our
awards ceremony he had died that night
this is a sea of former CEO of MetLife
he retired very wealthy goes to Croatia
Dubrovnik which is my favorite place in
the world and he buys a vineyard and all
he does is make wine and one day his son
is over there in his 2008 AIG is about
to go bankrupt I'm having dinner with
the CEO of AIG David Herzog and they
call him he says if we need you to help
us out this I'm not coming he says we
need your office I said look I'm good he
has three years to live if you got
cancer he's dying if you have three
years to live AIG calls them Bob and
mache gets up at a retirement it's on
his deathbed
three years to live doctor says publicly
on steroids all the time because it's
done okay he gets out of that not out of
bed he gets out of retirement comes to
AIG starts working
promotes David Herzog ably from American
general to AIG CFO they go to the
government they ask for eight hundred
eighty three billion dollar check and
when I'm having dinner I'll never forget
they said every day we were getting
hounded by regulators matters that
finally Bob memo she calls hey this
money we took from you we're not like GM
we're going to pay you back when you're
not going to bully us on a daily basis
I'm gonna tell you right now not a
single call I'm gonna let you know
exactly what with them but not one more
single call whoa okay Bob Mo she comes
cells up all the companies that they
didn't need some of them he held a
little bit longer to some day one plane
two edges a very big company he pasted
back one hundred eighty three billion
dollars plus another twenty three
billion dollars in interest or so then
he pays that back GM still has to pay
back so many other people haven't paid
back AIG pay back his credibility comes
back in the marketplace six months after
that he dies there's a Friday night when
this man died and all I remember about
Bob ben-moshe every time he and I were
together all I remember is a man with
presence with leadership with backbone
that people wanted to follow he wasn't
liked all the time but there's one thing
everybody knows that dude at the health
he's leading it as a CEO you're gonna be
fine he's a general the way he read he
led the company not everybody has this
personality but generally strong SEOs
they can be pushed around next number
nine they're great at asking questions
they're great at asking questions when
they don't understand something they can
ask questions when you want to find out
deeper issues they know how to ask the
right question a lot of times people
don't ask the right questions you can
ask questions but then it's asking the
right question that gets the right
answer that solves the bigger problem
not the smaller problem gray seals are
very good at asking the right questions
study great seals on what questions they
generally ask and you tell yourself man
I was thinking above the surface this
guy's thinking kill these are the
questions I want to be asking about
that's what you want to be thinking
about number 10 they want feedback what
do you think what are your thoughts what
do you think about this what do you
think about that and they know who to
get the right feedback from but it's
costly asking for feedback number eleven
they ranked great standards they're
always raising standards it's
uncomfortable being around strong feels
great shields they're always raising
standards most people believe it or not
don't even like working with great seals
because it's not comfortable it's always
raising standards almost a feeling of
it's not enough
it's not enough I mean I thought we're
doing it's not enough we're not there
yet we're not there it's always a
standard next every time I feel like I
get something you move the marker that's
the job of a leader every time I feel
like you go to you're moving a little
bit more man why when are you going to
be fully happy it's test that's what
makes them so special that's why history
books is going to favor Bob in motion
when he dies a bunch of people going by
his book because they want to know what
made him so special to save AIG from a
major you know the back of a major issue
that they were going to be facing right
because they know how to raise
everyone's standards I remember when
napa valley and bob demo she walks in
when there's a meeting going on
everybody in that room that reported to
him was uncomfortable it's so funny just
watching everybody they were
uncomfortable because it's a leader he
raised the standard he told them he said
this Adam even got started and he had
just become a CEO three months ago he
said this Napa Valley think he told
everybody this is not going to happen
for six years we got money to pay back
we got money to pay back that's how you
started a meeting this stuff not
happening anymore we got money to pay
back and you look at all of us and he
says hey we know we haven't been good
but we need your business
we need your business we need you to
work with us we need your business
flatout as I got a lot of respect for
men that talks like that and it's very
open about it number number 12 they've
built strong alliances remember I talked
on me he military
they build very strong alliances because
look you can only go somewhere so far by
yourself Amazon if you read Amazon's
case study from Harvard if you type in
Amazon case study and you type in Amazon
CEO
naughty Toys Toys R Us right if you
study what Amazon did a no one if Amazon
doesn't build an alliance with Toys R Us
forget about Amazon there is no Amazon
he gets credit for what he did with Toys
R Us so how did he do that building
strong alliances how did Steve Jobs when
he's about to go out of business go to
Microsoft Bill Gates his biggest enemy
and the meeting starts like this we have
been under this impression that in order
for Apple to win Microsoft has to lose
he says this in his talk just type in a
Steve Jobs speech
Microsoft has to lose he says this he
says that's not true he has to go to
Bill Gates and say I need 300 million
dollars Bill Gates his biggest enemy
gives them 300 million dollars but
imagine if he doesn't build out of life
tear out of business
everybody in Silicon Valley Palo Alto
seeing a guy from here one to Seattle to
raise money from the enemy
that's called building alliances today
you and I use our iPhone are all these
are the great devices because somebody
was stronger building alliances number
thirteen they speak different languages
what I mean by that I'm not talking
English Spanish shining on I'm not
talking about I'm talking to speak
different languages let me elaborate
they know how to talk to employees
different than the way they talk to
executives different than the way they
talk to salespeople different than the
way they talk to investors different
than the way they talk to media
different than the way they talk that
our family different paying on how to
speak this different and let me tell you
it ain't the same language it's not the
same language you cannot go talk to the
front desk clerk at a company that
you're the CEO and and talk to that
person as if that person say you know
full-on executive you can't because it's
a different language so you got to know
how to speak these different language
you can't go to an investment just kind
of lollygagging with them while they're
expecting returns on the tens of
millions of dollars that they give you
now walk into this room there's
different conversations regularly I did
a video that's called the seven
different audiences feels talked I think
it's seven different audience to your
style let's put the tab up here edgar
making sure we put it up there in the
link on the bottom you have to watch
this video it's seven different
audiences he'll speak to that'll help
you out understand they're sending how
they speak to those different customers
next number fourteen they know their
strengths very well but guess what being
their weaknesses even more here's why
they're very comfortable being weak
they're so comfortable being weak at
least the great ones are very
comfortable being weak because what they
do with the weakness is they recruit the
weakness so whatever they're weak at
they bring somebody whose strength is in
their weakness simple and the sooner you
identify your weaknesses the sooner
you're going to be able to leverage your
abilities to focus on your strengths and
not have to worry about your weakness
you can always recruit your weaknesses
by the way everyone's got weaknesses
focus on your strengths next point
number 15 they know what they know and
they know what they don't know let me
say it again they know what they know
and they know what they don't know
similar to weaknesses but it's not
meaning whatever they don't know they
know the person who can get them to the
answer of what they don't know it's
simple
Jeff it's a question technical ads this
phone cuts conscious I know who to call
to give me the answers to stuff I don't
know about and there
with it so they know what they know and
they know what they don't know number 16
is their very decisive they make the
decision boom I had Tom the other day
told mrs. Pat then when you want to fire
somebody you it's like that's quick
because I said I'm good at the moment I
know somebody doesn't fit in a stuff and
I've seen a trend of three times I'll
typically give somebody three chances
but if I notice somebody's just not
fitting and it happens like this over
and over and over again god they've got
to go to a different place it's like a
relationship that doesn't mean that
person is a bad person they're not going
to fit in a place like this because for
whatever reason this culture doesn't fit
with that person it constantly keeps
coming back that person may go to
completed some place and be happy just
not on this game we have a certain set
of culture here that we that we that we
have to follow through that we follow
through number seventeen timing timing
and business timing and statement timing
and comment timing and marketing
campaigns timing and brakes timing on
initiative timing on you know fun stuff
for the associates and employees and the
sales everything is about timing they're
very good at timing number eighteen
they're very strong drivers if there's
an initiative they will be driving it
over and over and over and over again
until you do it they will drive the
initiative non-stop that's what makes
these guys special they drive they're
going to drive the initiative and at the
moment you saw they forgot about it
you're about to give you a speech on
driving that energy of I everybody
should be focused on that they're
nonstop drivers and nineteen last point
here they're very good at rallying the
troops they're very good at rallying the
troops they know how to get the troops
going if it's sales if it's team if it's
Home Office if it's support they know
how to rally the troops so that's a 19
different qualities of a great CEO and
by the way if you're watching the saying
oh my gosh I got a lot of work to do all
this stuff is going to take years don't
expect to be good at this overtime it's
just good to look at it and say I can
improve in the following areas to become
a better CEO myself one day where other
people start looking at you as a CEO
instead of just going out and putting a
couple hundred dollars and getting a
vistaprint business card just to call
yourself a CEO without being said you
got any questions and thoughts comment
on the bottom if you have not subscribed
to the greatest channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs we need you to subscribe
to the greatest channel on entrepreneurs
and we challenge
I put it there out there to you I put it
there out there to you go tweet and
message anybody else and see if they can
stack against our channel on YouTube for
entrepreneurs we're that comfortable in
what we're doing with console improve
got a lot of great initiative that we
got coming out here but there's a lot of
channels that are purely about
motivation and regurgitating the same
thing we want to make sure we bring you
fresh content and we're just getting
started wait to hear what's coming out
here soon about stuff that's going to be
just purely innovative that no one's
ever done before because we believe the
world's a better place the more
entrepreneurs we can give birth to the
world keeps becoming a better and a
better place the more innovators the
more disruptive this place keeps getting
better and better and better and we need
your help to becoming a better
entrepreneur and we need your help to
spread the message of value came in to
other people so if you haven't
subscribed yet click on the button here
and then right next to you see the
notification will be Wonder first to get
notified every time a new video comes
out good catch that being said thanks
for watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]